being clicked dominant refers to a
tendency to rely on the gluteus maximus
that but more than quadriceps for
squatting type movements many people
believe that this is one of the key
determining factors predicting athletic
performance and while the term itself is
a little overplayed and may paint an
oversimplified picture is certainly true
that many of us struggled to properly
activate ugly's during movements that
should feature them front and center if
like many people you are currently quad
dominant then making a few changes to
your training may help you to tap into
greater explosive strength this makes a
ton of sense when you consider that the
gluteus maximus is the largest muscle in
the human body and that its main role as
propulsion jumping climbing and
sprinting it's often referred to as the
antigravity muscle and of course if
you're trying to build big glutes
because you think it looks good then you
need to activate the glutes properly
otherwise you won't get any benefits
from all of those squats if you perform
a large number of squats and you notice
that your quads are more fatigued at the
end and your glutes there was a large
chance that they are playing a
disproportionately big role in that
movement thus you are quad dominant you
might also notice that your lower back
does more work during back squats and
you may encounter knee pain quad
dominance can be somewhat genetic but
for many of us there was a simple fix
use flatter shoes without a heel to toe
drop and work more on your mobility
here's the thing if you're performing
squats using high structured shoes that
raise your heels off the ground then
that's going to force more weight onto
the balls of your feet especially as you
drop into the bottom of the squat you
are centrally leaning forwards this also
means that you now require much less
ankle mobility to get to the bottom see
this for yourself try performing a
pistol squat with shoes on and make a
note of how easy it is and whether you
fall over now perform the same thing
barefooted you'll find that it's easier
to stay balanced with the shoe on why
because you're being slightly tipped
forwards thus ensuring you don't fall
backwards with the shoe off however you
now need more ankle mobility to lean
forwards and to avoid falling the weight
is further back in relation to your
heels pistol squats with him without
heeled shoes are two entirely different
movements remove your shoes or use
barefoot shoes during the Scotland and
you'll be able to engage your glutes
more to further enhance this effect
you'll need to be more mindful of the
way you're moving during the squat that
means you want to focus on driving
through the
the foot the other problem of course is
that many of us spend all day sitting on
our buttocks this not only weakens the
muscles but it also deadens our
proprioceptive feedback entirely
eventually we actually lose some of the
ability to communicate with the gluts
thereby making it much harder to
activate them during training this is
then combined with unwanted adaptations
and lost mobility such as tighter hip
flexors which makes it extremely
difficult to drive through the posterior
chain a very simple way to solve this
one is to take regular breaks throughout
the day and again to a low resting squat
I do this in the morning as part of a
morning routine and anytime I get up to
make coffee it's made a huge difference
to my mobility and the flatus ISM and
just as useful is to include a few slow
air squats before starting my workout
proper and taking the time to feel which
muscles are activating but of course
when jumping during sports or in parkour
you don't actually drop into a deep
squat first more often you push off the
ball of your foot with only a slight
bend at the knee this is something that
JC Santana pointed out to me during a
recent chat so the answer here is to
make sure you're using your leg properly
by landing on the ball of the foot when
running or leading up to a jump this
while keeping the knee and ankle
directly below the center of gravity is
what will allow you to compress your
joints properly to absorb the impact and
return the energy through the ground
rather than just jolting through your
knees this is also what allows to
properly engage the glutes and it's also
another big advantage of going barefoot
or using minimal shoes author chung she
speaks at length about the hyper arch
mechanism he explains how forming the
stronger arch in the foots by landing on
the balls of the feet not the toes can
help to activate the glutes even more
then during propulsion starting with a
slight dorsiflexion of the toes this
will allow you to drive through the big
toe and activate the glutes even more in
short your leg acts like a kind of
spring allowing your hamstrings glutes
and quads to work together as they're
supposed to and your big toe is able to
help drive even more force through the
ground the big toe and the glutes are
necessarily connected seeing as the
glutes aid in external rotation of the
hip and this also makes a ton of sense
when you consider how many movements
from jumping movements to talking
movements involve driving power through
the big toe the toes are the bridge
between the massive muscles in our lower
body and the ground this is also why
according to Thomas Meyers we have
fascial connections called trains that
run from our feet to many other
muscles in our upper bodies because we
use them all together so often again
this is something you'll lose if you
constantly wear thick shoes that prevent
you from engaging your toes and
encourage you to land on your heel when
running the hallucis longus which is the
toe flex are responsible for the big toe
has also been shown to respond to direct
training providing improvement in
running speed at jumping height balance
and more my favorite options for toe
training are to use an isometric hold
trying to push the big toe into the
ground a trick used by ballet dancers
another option is to use calf jumps or
calf raises while being mindful to
really engage the big toes likewise we
can improve glute strength and
activation with specific targeted
training for the glutes glute bridges in
particular help to not only strengthen
the gliese but also stretch the hip
flexors and counteract the anterior
pelvic tilt they'll stabilize the knees
and help to be more mindful when running
and squatting another great one is step
ups do these with a barbell and you'll
be forced to drive through your
posterior chain with no option to let
the quads take over this is a fantastic
movement in general actually as it also
requires you to stabilize the hips and
to push off of a single leg two things
which again reflect the way we actually
use our legs in the real world another
thing you can try is a box squat and
here you're placing a box or something
else behind you as you squat down and
that allows you to really get down into
the squat without worrying about falling
over backwards and then to drive
yourself up through your buttocks
notice that these recommendations are
compounded not isolation isolating the
hamstrings and quads with resistance
machines and building them up
disproportionately might have actually
contributed to this issue for many of us
in the first place the aim is to
practice using these muscles together as
they were designed to be used and of
course we don't want to become glute
dominant at the expense of proper
balance either which is again why I
think a more appropriate term is glute
activation hope you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely subscribe if
you want more like this let me know in
the comments down below how you train
your glutes and whether glute activation
has been a problem for you in the past
if you like this kind of training for
performance first then you'll probably
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training you can find a
link to that in the description down
below and there's a discount on right
now whilst many people are still in
lockdown thanks a ton for watching this
one and I'll see you soon bye for now